[MUSIC]
What is one of the most versatile
communication tools everyone should have
in their toolkit?
The answer is asking questions.
I think questions are the Swiss Army
knife of communication.
A well timed question can accomplish
myriad communication tasks from building
trust and understanding
[MUSIC]
Fostering engagement and
calming your nerves through asking
good questions you can become a more
connected and authentic communicator.
My name is Matt Abrahams and
I teach Strategic Communication at
Stanford Graduate School of Business.
Welcome to Think Fast Talk smart,
the Podcast.
Today I am super excited to
have Deborah Shiffrin here.
Deborah is a lecturer at Stanford
Graduate School of Business where she
teaches to MBA courses she co
created spontaneous management and
creativity in the business ecosystem.
Prior to joining Stanford, Deborah spent
a decade as a national public radio
reporter, producer and director.
Welcome Deborah.
I love collaborating with you and
I look forward to our chat.
>> Me too.
>> Let's get started.
>> Why questions?
What do they do for us?
>> There's a range of goals and
purposes we have for
asking questions course
the big one is getting
information MAT What time is it
>> It's a little bit before noon
actually
>> So that's how that works I needed
information I asked Matt and
I got the information I needed In.
The second one is building relationships.
So you want to use it
to build relationships.
You ask people questions, you get to know
about them, they get to know about you.
And then there's other goals
you can use in the workplace.
You can ask questions to generate
ideas and foster creativity.
Then of course, it's a darker goals
like interrogate, or intimidate, or
avoid responsibility.
I think we'll take one, Matt, if it's
okay and break it down a little bit.
>> Absolutely.
I'd love to hear more.
>> So one of the big ones I mentioned
was building relationships.
So, if you're asking questions,
yes ou're signalling to the other
person that you value them.
You're taking time to
listen to their answers.
You're telling them that their
answers matter and they matter.
And the other one that I think is really
important is the type of question that
comes with coaching or mentoring people.
A lot of people are mentors,
a lot of leaders or
mentors to younger people
coming up in your organization.
For me,
I use it mostly in my coaching practice.
And I'll give you two
examples which I love.
Imagine I'm talking to someone and they
are deciding whether to take a job offer
I'll be talking and they'll be
weighing the pros and cons, right?
And then I'll stop them and
I'll say, what do you want?
And it's sort of a disruptive question.
It breaks the back and
forth between the tactical decisions and
it just takes things up to another level.
A second one is say someone is
telling me they're feeling inadequate.
When I hear that a couple of times,
I will say How is feeling inadequate
serving you, and what is it costing you?
And it really makes people stop and
think about it.
How is it supporting me and
how is it harming me?
And it makes people either take action
to change it or change their mindset.
>> I see, a key takeaway I had from what
you just said It's not just the question
you ask but it's the willingness to
actually ask the question in the first
place and then listen to the answer.
That's what can really help disrupt
the conversation or show that you really
are concerned with the person and
want to foster that connection.
Is that right?
>> Yes, absolutely, and
you have to have some sort of
>> Trust built up so this isn't a question
you're not going to meet someone for the
first time say that what do you want but
if you have a relationship
with someone of some sort but
there's some trust then you can
start using those questions.
>> Clearly questions can help us achieve
many ends that are positive and prosocial.
But you did mention that goals were not
always as friendly such as intimidation
and avoiding responsibility.
Can you talk more about these?
>> Yes, I can.
I'll mention interrogating.
So this is another way to
get information I suppose.
But you're doing it in
a very unpleasant way.
You might try to trap someone into making
a mistake or doing a gotcha question.
And so that's not very pleasant.
People can use questions to intimidate,
and
a lot of times that has to
do with power dynamics.
So they may want to use a question
to increase their power dynamic or
take advantage of a power
dynamic that already exists.
And the third one is
avoiding responsibility.
So, this brings me back to my improv
training days many years ago when
I was learning and we are told as
improvisers not to ask questions on stage,
and it may seem counter intuitive.
But the reason is, say,
you and I are in a scene, and
we're both creating it together.
There's no script.
So we're going back and
forth and building something.
And if I keep asking you questions, you
have to do all the work to come up with
all the ideas you don't want to do,
that you want to share the burden.
And there's an example that I
think most people can relate to.
So let's say we were going to go
to a movie
>> .Mmmh
>> And we were trying to figure out where
to go to dinner.
Say there's like five of us.
And some of them say, hey,
what do you want to go for dinner?
And the next person will say,
I don't know.
Where do you want to go for dinner?
[LAUGH] That could go to all five people.
>> You I think you're describing
my entire teenage years.
[LAUGH] I think that's what we did
every Friday and Saturday night.
Believe me it's so happens to me now
I'm in San Francisco and there's so
many options but I think the reason that
happens well eventually someone will step
up and suggest an actual restaurant but
I think that happens because one people
might not want to take the responsibility
of choosing the restaurant But
I think also people are afraid that if
they pick a restaurant and the rest of
the group doesn't end up liking the food,
that they're somehow responsible for
that so
isn't avoiding responsibility technique.
>> Talk to me a little bit about
how tone plays out in question
asking
>> Tone is really important tone can
turn a question negative or
positive, the same question.
Alright man, let's do a roleplay.
>> Okay, I'm ready.
>> Ready? Okay. You're going to be the
employee and I'm going to be the manager.
See how I did that?
>> Yes, ma'am.
>> Right.
So that this is your line,
and I will respond two ways.
You'll say the line I'll respond.
You'll say the line.
I'll respond again.
Your line is I have a plan to
automate customer service.
>> Alright.
I have a plan to automate
customer service.
>> What do you think it will
take to implement that plan?
Alright generally supportive.
Say it again.
>> I have a plan to
automate customer service.
What do you think it'll take
to implement that plan?
>> Wow, that's very different.
>> [LAUGH] Just emphasize one word
that and attend to the entire tone and
context of the meeting.
>> So your point Point Deborah is
very clear tone really does matter
in question asking and
I would argue in most communication.
having this conversation with you
has helped me realize that we can
get better answers if we
ask better questions.
So what goes into a good question?
I like to use words that are related
to values, words like impact.
An example would be Matt,
how does your decision Impact yourself and
the organization.
>> Mm-hm, yeah.
>> Something like, Matt,
what's important or what's at stake?
And one that I love is say it's
at the end of a project and
I'll say to you, Matt,
what can we create from here?
What can we create from here?
And that just assumes
that people are creative.
And once that's assumed,
people rise to the occasion, and
they free themselves to make suggestions
they might not otherwise make.
>> I really like that, I like positioning
the person in the conversation in a very
different perspective through
the question that you ask.
>> Can I add one more thing?
>> You sure can.
>> When the project is over,
people often forget to ask questions that
will get a catalogue of what went well.
What skills did you use to succeed?
How did your team accomplish the task?
So, when it's all said and
done, you got the project,
make sure you ask what went well.
>> I love your list of questions,
it's about open questions,
not closed questions.
It's about asking people to reflect, and
really think about the experience they
had, what it felt like, what they
learned from it, how they can apply it.
Thinking about impactful words, you
like how I did that, I used one of your
impactful words as [CROSSTALK]-
>> Uh-huh.
>> [LAUGH] And then-
>> Well done.
>> And then making sure that you
ask questions about when a project
is complete.
That's a fantastic advice for
good questions to ask.
Speaking of advice,
what advice would you give to business
leaders regarding question asking?
>> Whether you're a leader or
anywhere in the organization,
it takes some bravery to ask questions if
you don't know what the answer will be.
As adults, it's scary.
Kids ask a lot of questions.
>> Yes, they do.
>> [LAUGH] What color's the moon?
And when's dinner?
But adults don't ask as many questions
because it's a little scary.
You're handing the control of
the conversation to someone else.
And you have this fear that
it could harm your psyche.
In summary, my advice is to leave time for
questions, and be open to the answers,
ones that you want to hear or
answers that you don't want to hear.
And then assess how much
meeting time you spend asking,
versus telling people what to do.
So inquiry versus statements.
>> That last point about speaking time,
and
how they're allocated versus inquiry or
statements.
We've heard that before when
Bob Sutton was on the podcast.
We spent a little bit about it, and he
said from his perspective in his research,
he's found that leaders who ask more
questions are perceived as better leaders,
have better data to make decisions and
actually people like them more.
So, there's a whole lot of value to
following the advice of making sure
to leave time for questions,
be open to the answers.
And then pay attention to how much
time you're actually asking questions
versus just making statements.
So thank you for
that really important advice.
Now you've done a lot of question asking
throughout your life as a reporter,
as a coach and a teacher.
What are some best practices for question
asking, and does the context matter?
>> Yes, the context definitely matters.
You have to know who's in the room, what
their agendas are, what their needs are.
So that's something you have to figure
out before you figure out the question or
even the type of question you want to ask.
In terms of best practices,
I'll frame it this way,
I feel like a lot of best practices
stem from a mindset of curiosity.
So if I were interviewing you, Matt, but
this is not just for interviewing, but
if I were an NPR reporter,
like I was interviewing you.
And you say something that surprises me,
or has emotional charge,
I want to follow up on that and
ask you another question.
Sure, I've come with my list of ten
questions to ask you those questions.
But I don't have to stick to that script.
I can just go off script and come back.
What I do as a journalist
is I have my list, but
I say in advance these three questions
I absolutely need answers to.
But the rest if I hear something
interesting, I go for it.
>> That's really, really interesting.
So if you take time to listen
thoroughly and ask questions,
you can actually learn
a lot more information.
>> When you think about being curious,
you're listening for
information that's interesting and
surprising.
And you're also in a state where
you're curious about the other person.
And you're not just asking them questions
from your own frame of reference.
Matt, if I were interviewing you-
>> Uh-oh.
>> [LAUGH] I would want to do questions
that delight or engage you or
questions you may not have
thought about before.
So here's an example.
I was at my brother's house, and
he had a friend over who was a physicist.
He worked at UC Berkeley as a postdoc.
So I thought, I'm interested in physics,
but I don't know much,
but I know something.
I'll ask him the question that I know.
So I said, are you a theoretical
physicist or an applied physicist?
He answered the question,
it was okay question, but
he didn't get very excited about it.
So then I thought for
a minute, and I asked him,
what's something surprising that
happened for you this year?
And suddenly he lit up,
he got so animated.
He was talking about these things
that he had done in his lab, and
he was picking up things on
a table like a cup or a plate.
And showing me how maths works
by using a cup and a plate.
And so at the end, I found out that
he discovered something pretty cool.
It was connecting mathematics
to a particle that
scientists think is
related to dark matter.
So of course, I can't understand
the full scope of what that means,
not being a physicist,
but it was pretty amazing.
And if I hadn't asked that question,
that never would have happened.
>> Wow, so again, it's being curious, and
really thinking about how to put
the other person in position where
they can share an answer that's
really meaningful for them.
>> Yeah, and I would say this is good for
leaders as well.
When you ask someone a question,
ask them a question that enables them
to speak from their perspective.
So you ask those open questions,
give them a chance to speak
from their base of knowledge.
And not what they think you want them to
say based on your frame of knowledge.
>> Excellent way to summarize that.
Let me ask you this.
Do you have a secret weapon or
trick up your sleeve that you use
to get to insightful and
surprising responses?
>> I do,
I call it the killer last question.
>> Ooh, tell me more.
>> And I'll have to tell you
what it is and how you ask it.
That's a very important part.
There's several steps.
I'm talking with someone and
we've had a conversation.
We've built rapport and it's time to
end the conversation or the interview.
So, I say to them,
is there anything I didn't ask
you that you think is important?
And then here's the next step,
and this is really important.
I had to wait in silence and
be comfortable with the silence.
And then nine out of ten times,
the person says, I don't think so.
But then you wait again, another,
it could be like eight seconds.
And then they will say the most
interesting thing that they said in
the whole interview.
I think this happens because you
are turning the control over to them,
you're handing them the mic,
you are putting them in the driver's seat.
And so it creates a condition where
they're more likely to share something Or
at the end of this conversation,
we've been talking about a lot of things,
it lets them ask a question of
themselves and get you an answer.
So something they're excited about.
>> It's interesting that you bring that
technique up of waiting because waiting is
something I always coach people to do.
People don't like that awkward pause,
so they'll ask a question and
if nobody responds immediately,
then they'll just move on.
>> Right.
>> I had never really
thought of that pause,
allowing people to really
do some self reflection.
And really having that be an opportunity
for people to dig deeper,
and provide more information or
disclose something that's a little
more personal, so I really like that.
>> Let's do an experiment for
our listeners.
>> Okay.
>> I'm going to
ask you a question that
you've never heard, right?
You don't know what I'm going to say.
>> I have no idea.
>> [LAUGH]
>> I'm locked in this cone of silence.
>> And then ask it to you once and
then I'll ask it in a different way and
see how the results change.
>> All right, so
I'm going to answer it twice.
Go for it.
>> Yes, here's the first question.
Today's podcasts will be really great,
right?
>> Absolutely,
this should be a great podcast.
>> Let me ask in a different way.
What is important to you
about today's podcast?
>> I so much hope that people
listen to your passion for
asking questions to really bond and
build on relationships people have.
That I hope when people are done
listening that they feel
they have the tools and
the energy to go do what you do.
>> So those are the two questions so
you can see the difference.
The first question, the way I asked it,
I didn't get any information.
And then did you feel
a little bit pigeon holed?
Like it wasn't really what you wanted to-
>> There really was only one answer.
>> [LAUGH]
>> What am I going to say to that?
>> Totally but
the second question really allowed me to
give insight into the work that I did and
you did in preparation for this.
And really let people know
that we really want people
to take good value from what it is we do.
So, I totally appreciate the difference.
And I can see why you
are a good question asker.
So, thank you for that.
Now, this whole time we've talked today
Deborah has been about questions and
answering.
Would you indulge me and answer the three
questions that I ask of all of our
guests at the end of our podcast?
>> Absolutely, if you listen to
the answers, I'll tell you anything.
>> [LAUGH] I will absolutely listen.
Question number one.
If you were to capture the best
communication advice you ever received
as a five to seven word presentation
slide title, what would that be?
>> Be present and build on others' ideas.
This is an improve wisdom
that's come down decades and
decades to me today and
to people I'm teaching.
>> Excellent, thank you.
Let me ask you question number two, who is
a communicator that you admire and why?
>> I'm really interested
by Kamala Harris right now.
She is very calm, at the same time,
she's very passionate.
It's a great combination.
And she owns the room.
A lot of politicians are very stiff but
she's not, she moves but
she moves with purpose.
So when she moves,
there's a reason and it's very clear.
And the last thing about her is that she
has mastered the smile for all occasions.
She has the right smile,
whether she's debating Mike Pence,
or introducing Joe Biden.
She has the right smile and
smiling can be really tricky for women.
>> Tell me more about smiling and
the challenges involved in that.
>> I've seen a lot of women be given
the communication advice to smile more.
And I think it's really undermining
because we know what we want to say and
how we want to say it.
And if we're given the advice smile more,
essentially we're being
told to be nicer, to seem more pleasant,
to even be more feminine.
And those can be really undermining
messages and I see it all the time.
So, sometimes as a woman, it's hard
to remember that you own your smile.
You own your presentation, and
that you should do what's best for you.
>> Absolutely, absolutely.
Let me ask question number three.
What are the first three ingredients that
go into a successful communication recipe?
>> I want to go back to again be present.
And I'll tell you a little
bit more about why.
It keeps you grounded,
it connects you to your audience of one or
a thousand, and it keeps that inner
critic, that judge away from you.
We all have that critic that right now,
say, I'm talking to you.
I am thinking about what I
said just a minute ago, and
judging it, was that stupid?
And then right now, I'm talking to you and
I might find a judge,
I might be judging myself,
what I'm saying right now is stupid.
And then move on to the next question.
I'm not listening,
because I'm thinking about the stupid
thing I said a moment ago.
[LAUGH] That
>> Right.
>> [LAUGH] Judges are really powerful,
and if we can be present,
we can move that judge out of the way,
that's number one.
>> Number two, I would say, rigorously
prepare, but be ready to go off script.
You need both of those pieces.
You really have to prepare, I know you've
said this in the past, awesome that.
That there's no substitute for
preparation,
but you need to be ready to go off script.
Lead with energy and
commitment to the audience.
If you do that,
you will engage your audience.
They see that you want to be there,
that you're excited to be there,
and that you are there for them.
100%, and when you do that,
it will give you more confidence.
And confidence will improve your
credibility in front of your audience.
>> I really like your recipe a lot.
Being present and preparing but
being willing to go with what's needed
in the moment, really powerful.
And then of course being audience centric,
and doing so
in an energetic way will help.
You know Deborah, thank you so much.
As we wrap up,
I find myself asking a question.
>> [LAUGH]
>> What are my takeaways from today?
And the answer is abundantly clear.
Questions can really
help our communication.
By taking the time to plan our questions
and actively listen to the answers,
we can build camaraderie and closeness.
And ultimately improve our communication.
Thank you so much for
your time and for your insight.
>> It's been my pleasure.
>> Thank you for listening to
Think Fast Talk Smart the podcast,
a production of
Stanford Graduate School of Business.
To learn more, go to gsb.stanford.edu.
Please download other episodes
wherever you find your podcasts.
[MUSIC]